[Music]
alcohol I like getting drunk
I hate hangovers everything hurts the
try guys gonna try different alcohols
and compare them we want to see how
different alcohols affect us for weekend
four types of alcohol watch out
this is science ladies and gentlemen
barely science there's a lot of myths
about alcohol intake and there are some
tips that you could use to be safer that
are based on research
how are we gonna measure the quality of
our drunkenness one how are you did I
say that right how turn to the hangover
how do you feel the next morning and
three the personal factor my third
factor is how hungry I get I notoriously
get wild and crazy when I get drunk when
I go out drinking with my wife we go
home early how much I talk to girls my
favorite thing is beer you can just sit
back drink beer have good conversations
we decided to move our drinking to a
brewery beer contains more carbohydrates
and calories than some of the other
alcohols it's a it's a conversational
drink
it's a treat to be had with friends so
silly it's absorbed more slowly because
the other calories are being worked on I
wanted to kick off a little steam I
wanted to take it easy I was being bored
out of my mind let's just continue
drinking
were the nine Texans this is the thing
that Eugene does is that when he's drunk
he just reads is not that I'm bored it's
just that people are boring Ned was
barely drinking I'm turnt City he wasn't
drunk
but he was so like he's hunger factor
was good I get hungry guys I love to eat
Zack had negative girl points I don't
think Zack talked to one woman the
entire night and I talked to maybe fifty
your night overall it was okay for me I
didn't get too drunk I wasn't too
outgoing actually now that I'm saying
this a lot it was pretty awful for me
but no hangover hey we're about to go
meet at Chris Ryan occurs birthday party
really do the test to see which would
cause the worst hangover you got to make
sure that you're giving the person equal
amounts of alcohol in that beverage very
scientific
vodka sucks it's just rotten potato
juice but I always associated with a
really hardcore college party there's a
gong in this town I can I got crazy bike
and I got two crazy
binge drinking can be very dangerous and
that's where someone takes a large
amount of alcohol in one day in one
sitting or one evening
I don't actually know how many drinks
that have this is this something went
horribly wrong last night
that's where accidents may happen
people's judgement and their physical
coordination is impaired mango chutney I
ate four sandwiches by Eugene where does
he ever go
goodbye try guys at house party they are
not gonna go to this one boy is strip
club will you guys come well I woke up
this morning with all of my makeup still
on and this in my purse I nod cut
there's only one thing you can do and
it's go to a [ __ ] shirt bump
sure enough Eugene and Kelsey disappear
within 15 minutes cool vodka makes you
irresponsible I drank more than I
expected to stay that way later than I
expected to being in a party environment
encouraged me to rage more with my
friends tonight
they took all my covers dogs stopped
quite frankly we don't know what the
underlying cause of the hangover is ah
think I drank enough water your thinking
and your judgment and your motor skills
are impaired it's all just keep lying on
my face to my face out I feel pretty
great no hangover at all man it's gonna
work out I myself was surprised to find
out that there's a fair number of
automobile accidents that occur when
they're suffering from a bad hangover do
you guys like sleeping with people once
it'd be fancy
it's our third Friday it's one day some
things we actually do pretty often is we
start drinking at the office before we
go out so Zack and I went to the liquor
store next door bought a couple bottles
of red one bottle of white because white
wine you got to let it aerate just
hanging out let's relax it's de-stress
with some wine it's been a Friday it's
been afraid it's got some wine at the
office strength there someone at quinces
rap party we drink their tea check and
guide a tongue check
then of course we went to a restaurant
and I feel that that was where it was
most appropriate to have wine free right
is like when someone you meet - so see
their premise I've never thought bad but
at this point I'm realizing man I'm
spending way way more money I just
ordered about a hundred dollars with a
food and drinks for myself problem -
with drinking wine all night wine can
make you sleepy all alcohol is sedated
it's a sedative when my wife gets sleepy
that means it's time for me to get
sleepy then I got home and I think I ate
some potatoes Eugene ditched us as he is
wanted to do I to be honest I was pretty
grateful for a relatively tame night the
next morning red wine in susceptible
people can cause a headache I woke up
with the worst wine headache ever
chronic headaches like migraines they're
susceptible to headaches and the red
wine triggers it it's the quickest way
to go from point A to point B this is
this is the one that I have feared the
most from a biological perspective
you're gonna get a vaster effect and a
slightly greater effect from a single
shot of hard liquor
congrat the wine India I have to go to
the airport I think I'm still drunk oh
no what a time mistakes that will be
made you had tequila shots it put little
dots on a hand we're dancing all my
living room with my dog or chef and a
little over an hour don't feel drunk yet
which is the problem it's easy to get in
over your head pretty quickly with shock
I didn't feel anything and now I feel a
lot the more thing about it I think all
we did was take shots in Vegas
maximum amount of alcohol intake that's
considered healthy no more than five
drinks in a 24-hour period for men and
no more than four drinks in a 24-hour
period for women if you feel like you've
drank so much that you don't remember
what happened or you've done things that
you later regret those are some of the
warning signs that suggests you could
have a problem I realized that because
of the way I party I didn't really know
what happened with the other three guys
the other nights hey guys I'm gonna try
something for the first time in my life
I'm gonna drink responsibly
this was the first night that I've ever
gone out drinking with Eugene that he
actually was like you know what I'm
hanging out with you guys don't drink so
much
have a little water and you can help one
of your best buds get some get some
action she's got two cats yo my friend
Zach likes cats oh so like I'm not a
kind of guy who's gonna like kiss until
his tongue was just plunging in her net
is giving money to the go-go dancers
with his wife's support what happened by
the other night we're headed home then
they catch a plane tomorrow
whoa then the best part of all but the
objective to be there with your friends
and have a good time and really change
the type of drinking night for me she
went home I go in pee and Zach's house
we have one last goodbye and then I take
my uber home people please I win
I'm the best drinker Kibaki I did it I'm
the best drinker officially hey it's me
in the mirror
I have to go to the airport I think I'm
still drunk oh no per usual I feel fine
0.012 I am still drunk
I feel looking better because I remember
everything and I stayed with my friends
the entire time what I've learned
through this entire experience is that
alcohol is poison in my body hates it
you can get too drunk on anything and
that's just not safe you can have fun
without alcohol but if you are gonna
drink make sure that you're doing it in
a situation that's safe make sure that
you're not gonna drive don't drink alone
drink at your own pace stick responsibly
know your limits don't push them there's
no point in having fun and drinking if
you can't remember any of it don't get
you up get a little stuff dad's our day
after drinking so natural response of
the body is to try to get that out so
both ends start to go dads are like a
level